Film Courage: Bill you've said you're an introvert? Bill Duke, actor/filmmaker/author:  Yes.
I I've never been my jokes are sometimes
I say things to people and I find a lot
of things funny but I'm not necessarily
an outgoing person to a lot of events
and I think it's good news in the bad
news because being out with people it's
very important in this industry for
relationships. But I'm very selective
to put it that way. Film Courage: I can identify. I'm
also an introvert and I'm also sensitive
to my environment and I was just
wondering how have you accomplished what
you've had with being an introvert and
some of the walls that have builds but
also some of the creativity that it
creates - from being alone or being in a
quiet environment? Bill: Well, I think I've
learned how to split the balance between
being a relatively decent businessman
and also protecting my family and myself
from the you know the industry in terms
of it become like something to eat or
devour if you are human and I never
wanted my goddaughter for example to be
swept up into the industry and the press
and all that stuff and so I do my best
to create a balance so I definitely want
to use the press and stuff when I have a
film or an app or a podcast or
television whatever it is that I want to
promote but um there are limits sure
so so I've heard some people say that
they're extroverted introverts would you
say that as an actor if someone is an
introvert or they are sensitive that
that is a good thing to adopt when you
have to do a networking event
or beyond yes I mean you have to be
aware of your balance you have to
understand that you know your you owe
the investor in your project the
responsibility of helping you get their
money back so you go on the road you go
in the world you help market you help
promote because that's part of your job
because they've trusted you with their
dollars whatever your personal choices
are is one thing but when you're doing
work if the marketing getting out there
is gonna help sell with filming get
eyeballs and put down words back into
the investors pocket that's your
obligation and your responsibility and
so I guess part of being a professional
is showing up even when you don't want
to which I've heard whether it's singers
actors whatever go through we all have
days we don't want to be somewhere but
knowing that it's part of what we have
to do and beyond how can I say a friend
of mine once said you become a memoir of
mini faces that you have to put together
to survive and to let people know they
appreciate it even if you're going for a
difficult time
it's always about you it's about your
responsibility your obligations all of
those things and it's about you too you
have to make a priority and taking care
of yourself but it's a very competitive
business a difficult business and when
people trust you with their dollars you
have to be responsible for the ROI and
you can't be just thoughts about me
doesn't work
you said that acting allows you to be
many things that in your personal life
you may not be able to be but on camera
you can be that maybe I'm paraphrasing a
bit well I think we're all of us are
everything and people say why can you
say that I'm a woman with a child I'm
not a murderer okay
suppose somebody just came up and made
sure a baby in the head with a hammer
what would you call your response to
that if you picked that hammer up no
one's saying you're a murderer no one's
saying you're anything but you're
everything and if you're hired to do a
job the director does not hire you to
act like that person the director hires
you to become that person and that's
something that most people understand
about acting acting is not I don't that
word is annoying because it means you're
pretending acting is not pretending
acting is becoming it's surrendering to
the spirit of whatever you're that
character you're describing is so thing
called stage fright that's when you're
in the middle you've given part of
yourself up to be the character but your
ego and your fear and paranoia is
watching how you give it up and tries to
control the shape of that giving up but
real actors like the ones that I adore
the Kate Winslet's and the Meryl
Streep's and the denzel's when he's
really in it and the Sam Jackson's
the philip Seymour Hoffman's and the
Jeffrey writes and when those people go
there there's no there's nobody there
except that character and that's
admirable it takes courage and people
don't understand because sometimes you
not control your you want to ride if the
trust and the person you trust the
director to say that I ride right what
do you think cuz you don't stand outside
and look at your ride you ride and
that's what real great actors do flop
scene one half is where my favorite
actress of all time I think he was
brilliant can someone still be great and
have stage fright they can be great and
have stage fright making me really good
and have stage fright but to surrender
totally to the moment and to totally
respond to what the other person that
you're acting with is doing that's her
that takes courage you're not watching
yourself anymore you're watching the
person you're with and the scene you're
not watching how you react to what they
do you're responding like we're talking
right now I'm not trying to be a special
anything I'm just responding to what
you're asking me and that's what acting
should be so overcoming stage fright is
is less being sort of this defiant rebel
oh I don't care what they think of me
and more being so immersed in the moment
that all of that is you don't see it
one of my great acting teachers when I
was a very young actor I asked a similar
question he said I'm gonna make it real
simple for you he said it's like falling
into darkness backward imagine just
falling into darkness backward no
control of your landing you're gonna be
caught or not just fall embrace it well
supposes our rock back there or suppose
there's a I don't know no pillows and
just hard floor the writer is saying to
you I want you to fall into darkness
backward I'm giving you all the
description the director and I of who
the character is we've had rehearsals
and discussions about who this Peyman
being is I do not want you to describe
them to me I want you to become them by
falling into darkness backward can you
do that thinking about the trust fall
that sometimes they do in acting classes
where you're going to have someone
behind you for those that can do that is
that the ones that can cross over and
there are people that can't do the trust
fall it's those are the ones that work
with okay that's good to know
okay is the ones that can't do the trust
of all who was that can't they once I
can't okay
because if you can't I made love you as
a person I seen your potential but I'm
working for Network studio and investors
they divide my day not in two minutes
but seconds they put a dollar value on
every second every second I have to
spend convincing you to fall the
darkness backward it's a second taken
away from me making my day if after
three hours I get you to fall in the
darkness backward and it but I had to
cut three scenes from my day and I'm
behind three scenes this is not a good
thing I expect you to come prepared
is it hard I understand that but it
could have been a florist
so your latest film created equal how
many people would show up on set every
day depending on the day and courthouse
scenes lots and lots a smaller scene
small crew stunt people but if you're
directing you're in charge of a lot of
folks 30 40 50 sometimes 100 more doing
a big feature film TX 210 state your
vision to everybody from the Teamsters
to the actors to the first and second ad
the DP sound would robe props costume
because for me I have a lot very
paranoid director I go through my sets
at least five to seven times every set i
block my DP everybody comes with me they
knows and I have my assistant right my
shot list so every angle every shot
every setup my entire staff and crew
have it a week before I ship there's no
drama no mystery you come to the set
cast comes in another blocking it may
make some adjustments but they know
everything so that when we're there we
work it's not figuring things out
rehearsals give you room to for the
actors that don't feel comfortable
sitting here if I sit over here fine
that's not a problem but we don't say oh
wait a minute instead of waiting for the
Sun to shine wait for the Sun to set
they don't happen
it makes you didn't make your day you
just have to be it's planning directors
they're in charge of three things not
two things to create a process if they
translate your vision to everybody but
the second thing is that their managers
the managers of three things time people
and money it's mathematics you have 12
hours in a day that you can work so
number of scenes they're broken down to
two setups each set up you have a
certain number of minutes to make your
day Accra comes in on prepared and
that's a big problem so work as a team a
collaborative effort understand their
obligations and responsibilities if the
director always the first one on set
would you sometimes see other crew
members actors show up before you and
what did that say about them there are
some actors I won't mention their names
but there they are so involved in
legitimacy of what they do they're there
before the crew and me
they just sit on this set and sit in
this seat they know they're gonna be in
sometimes or if they're if it's supposed
to be their bedroom they'll go on their
bedroom and touch the props and do what
is never become familiar with the
pictures on the wall and what's in the
closet what kind of bed sheets are they
what color is the bedding how soft of
the pillows and why those pills that
softer why are they harder or is the
blind closed or is it open and there's a
curtains on the wall and why was that
color chosen for this sheet and ah okay
and they're comfortable because it's
their bedroom for the laughs
fifteen years so sometimes they come to
this set two days before and they just
sit there and they become organically
ingrained some of the great actors have
their own ways of becoming the truth of
what they're supposed to be and I get
there and they're there hey Bill how you
doing man no I hear me you know what I'm
doing working I see yeah thank you
because I respect that
they don't just wait for you to tell
them what to do they have there only
because I'm an actor too as you start
surrendering to a character that the
author is written it's it's gonna sound
crazy but the character tries to live
through you if you accept him or her I
was playing a character once in a movie
forgot which one he was and week before
us pulls a film I started doing this
never done that my life my girlfriend at
times what are you doing
I said wait she said you're going I said
no I'm not she says okay watch find this
later I'm going that was the character
coming through me and so I put that in
part of the film because I knew
something that is being expressed in
that person and it's trust trusting your
instincts yourself and your talent so if
an actor wants to do all those things
bring little idiosyncrasies or tics or
or show up three hours early is that
something that they almost feel like
they need permission to do because I
could see a new actor wanting to do
those things
but being scared because they don't want
to offend anybody or whatever you're a
new actor and and you know what acting
is and you have a good director they'll
give you the permission that you need to
do and be the best you can good
directors their ego is listening if I'm
shooting a scene with the star of the
movie in a car and we shot half the
scene for lunch and should have the
scene after lunch and the an intern an
assistant or a caterer comes up to me
says hey Belle bill I say what the
license plates before you want my lunch
was straight but now it's crooked I
don't say you're the caterer you're an
assistant mind your own business that's
stupid I say thank you very much because
I didn't see that and I have my
assistant going straight at the license
plate you know why because I still good
directing credit that person's no less
than me that person helped me out but
some people throw phones at I don't they
don't understand these idiots going
phones in people's faces and this is
real t-wave like they're superior to
human beings and an attitude of
superiority like other people earths
it's annoying because they're all gonna
die
y'all bleed I do believe I have no proof
of course I don't want it that may all
go to the bathroom I do number two they
stink if they don't if they can prove
they don't stink when they go to the
bathroom I will worship them but until
that moment occurs don't come to me with
that crap yours that you stink I stink
you're both stink cool do your damn job
so we're gonna assume that they do if
you're asking me if I'm going in the
bathroom I'm not I'm saying we're yeah
we'll just we'll we'll err on the side
of caution of course great question yes
good nice suit err yeah yeah Arizona I
like though she said she said hear hear
this is a tricky question but it's up to
you if you want to answer it navigating
Hollywood agendas sometimes what happens
and I clearly don't have to tell you
this I'm sure this has happened to you
and your career but something will
happen with someone someone will maybe
it wouldn't even be burning somebody but
somebody's offended and then they come
back to you years later as if nothing
had ever happened like you're great
friends or they friend you on social
media as a professional how do you
handle that do you say you know what
it's water under the bridge
are there levels some it's water at the
bridge some it's please stay over there
I think I'm good others is you know what
it was a misunderstanding I'm fine I
think it's both I think
some people you can forgive and forget
some people and cannot forgive or forget
there are other people you can forgive
and not forget such as people you can
forgive and forget forgive and not
forget it depends on what they've done
if it's the kind of betrayal from our
friend but that not only stabbed you in
the back what held the knife and twist
it a few times to make sure that would
ever trust you trust you adding them
died it's not that she wouldn't work
with them again it's called trust but
verify but
and a martial arts teacher once and give
us lessons in terms of say teacher said
you know if a man wants to fight you run
away from him as hard and fast as you
can he said but if he runs after you and
he catches you make sure he never chase
you again
he said revenge is a dish best served
cold don't shout don't scream don't it's
like playing chess he said don't be
playing chess in the checkers the
checkers of the chess game said play
chess it's not about the outcome it's
the process too
so the trail happens all the time
betrayal rejection and this is part of
our industry it's it's that you for the
young people come in this business XO
man and I talk all the time about this
is like they come in with dreams and
hopes
nice Bret's and butts and faces and hair
and bodies and muscles and all that
stuff and we were talking yesterday man
is going to the acting to this road so I
said look up the percentage of Astra and
SAG actors in the Union the percentage
that work annually out of a hundred
percent certain
was 20 and out of the 20% how many made
over $50,000 a year has no year 5 over
10 less about 10%
they go over $100,000 a year just deal
with those numbers you're coming in here
with hope and dreams right along with
thousands of other people that look as
good as you on the same day your coven
coming they say don't take rejection
personally but I have to get rejected
once or twice you can understand that
but suppose you're rejected every other
day for nine years what's that do to you
okay something called pain self
deprecation self-doubt and a lot of
people bury those things with liquor and
drugs and I did that for a while when I
first started it's just so painful thank
God I found meditation but I see kids
out here now on the street they came
here with hopes and dreams and you're my
Senate I mean literally on the street
that now there's hope I mean there's
luck and hoping everybody's keep
dreaming they should understand the
business too and the good part about
today is you're not the wait to be
discovered you can you can click
podcasts and webisodes up if I said
something relevant and you get one or
two million eyeballs guess what
they come to you
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia been
out for ten years now right I started I
was webisodes you survey uncle dark
girls by girls right millions of
eyeballs got a big deal with HBO
tangerine was that Sundance two years
ago a movie made with for iPhones
anybody waiting I'm waiting for them to
see how wonderful I am
these guys got tired of waiting man hey
someone discover myself and they did and
guess what when they when they got that
kind of inner confidence and self that
evaluation some changed something
happened I'm good for them
I love what you said about rejection
sometimes when I'll do you know I'll
watch videos or I'll read about an actor
or a writer or a musician I find that
actually some of them that have really
thrived they had a very painful early
rejection and I'm just wondering does
that almost because you had that first
early painful rejection any new
rejections it's like okay casting
director didn't like me well my own
father rejected me so what could be
worse
you know so I see that sometimes I've
seen I've actually looked at a lot of
people's lives or nothing like wow that
person I really admire they grew up in a
tough situation and I'm wondering if
that almost helps in some sense I think
your ability to deal with pain and how
you deal with that determines your life
journey yeah every rejection and this it
sounds crazy but every rejection is
painful but it's not personal
of course the 20 people before you are
rejected also they weren't rejected
because they're not talented and you may
be more talented than the person who got
that job not because they're more
talented than you but because and this
is gonna sound crazy because if you have
fifty thousand social media followers
and they have five million because it's
a job so it's not personal and it's not
meant to be personal it's business
they put 5060 million dollars into the
movie you may do the scene very well but
that other person is gonna bring five
million eyeballs so just suppose 10% of
them buy tickets that's 500,000 tickets
for opening day you know and it sounds
harsh but I have a question if you put
50 million downwards or 150 million
dollars into a film when you be
interested on the ROI of your investment
I mean you may love Henry but if Sam can
bring you 50 million eyeballs for the
hundred and fifty million you've spent
you're going to think about it
so we think they're mean and horrible
people no no no businessman and women
bill if you could pick five books that
you would be allowed to read every year
and only those five books what would
they be
there was a library police and I said
I'm allowing you five and that's it god
I love books I'm just trying five yes
sorry I know that's limiting but an
empire of their own oh it's his name
seen empire of their own what's the book
I always talk about in 1984 but the one
would about the mythology
Jean Irvin was his husband and all the
majors to all the major guys read this
book hero with a thousand faces
that's an incredible book incredible
book about all the stories of the world
have a certain commonality no matter
what they are Steven Spielberg use it
Lucas who uses it everybody all use it
the hero's journey what is the hero's
journey and there's a commonality to
every single hero's journey I read a
book by Steven Pressfield recently that
every as often as I can and it's called
the war of art it's a take-off on Sun
Tzu's the art of war and it talks about
what is what what is it that stops the
average person
from accomplishing anything they want to
accomplish
countless the book is this thick and the
book pisses you off so bad because from
the first page you say to yourself he's
talking about a and he says the father
and mother of incompetence this
procrastination in the rationalizations
we come up with to justify a
procrastination hours and days of
thinking why we're not doing it and
justifying it instead of doing it
he says it's easier to know the hand
that's choking you then to let another
hand in this is motoki worse
you're not dead but you're asking me to
put another near me I don't know I don't
know this you know I know this because
that's my it's a brilliant brilliant
going in then there are books forgot the
author's name right now but one is
called the dip of them when it's called
the Purple Cow Seth Godin Seth go yeah
oh
is he great or not he has a podcast -
yeah he's he's brilliant brilliant books
it is thick but he tells you and shows
you accomplishment what is
accomplishment that's four and then my
favorite poet is TS Eliot
Four Quartets it's the last thing I
think before he died he talks about how
every piece of poetry but before that is
the meaningless delay just as right now
he talks about what he's learned in life
and puts it and put and put it before
that Federico Fellini and Frank Capra -
my favorite directors of all time
reading eight and a half the era I watch
and sometimes look at the script of
lists
it's just goes to Washington and it's a
wonderful life the message is the the
courage that he had at that time and
when he was tortured by McCarthy for
saying he thinks he said in look he was
a bigger communist but he went on and
did it anyway he has encouraged my
career and I can't remember the name of
the director now but the script I could
beat over and over and over again
because it's so brilliant and the film I
can watch a thousand times was it so
brilliant came out around nine to ten
years ago called Run Lola Run I've ever
seen that one scene the trailer you
gotta watch it I know he's a genius
when I say genius he never got the
credit he deserved but the film is toe
pictorially and structurally through
methodologies that no one else has ever
seen done it's that way it's like a
giving one example but it's it's a but
it's a 20 hour per hour thing this
woman is called by her boyfriend
supposed to deliver drugs to the drug
dealer doesn't have their drugs hit set
the money to the drug dealer because he
lost the package on the plane and named
drug dealers coming in like three to
three hours
and he's got to be at a drug store and
you have a pharmacy to meet the drug
dealer if the drug dealer sees not the
money he's gonna get killed so his
girlfriend does everything she can to
make sure so the film is divided in to
all the attempts she makes and it starts
her back at the apartment over and over
again and runs down the steps to
different places now as she runs down
the steps
she must down the steps she's running
doors open to older ladies apartment and
it moves over the older lady shoulder
into the TV and the TV shows are here
opening down the steps when she gets in
the street she passes people and
everybody she passes you see in five
seconds a flashback of their entire
lives who they are and when she gets to
the place where she tries to get the
money for him and it fails you go back
to the appointment the phone rings and
he says I'm gonna die if you don't get
here she gets up and she once again to
try to get the money from someplace else
when you see people working harder than
you what does that do for you Spira me I
see working be working harder than me
I can't imagine that but if I do as far
as me to work harder I mean good is not
good enough and great it's not good
enough
excellence excellence your names on it
and even if you had another budget you
needed you gotta take what you have and
do the best you can but you're given you
said to Nick one may look like 20 you
got to do it and takes work and sleep is
not something you do you always like
this
I had a parents who taught me ethics
that I didn't know they were teaching at
the time I was very very young and my
father wants to say to my sister and I
bill and Evonne always remember this
you're no better than anybody else but
nobody else is better than you
and they said never ask anybody for
anything go get it
my father worked three jobs mother
worked two seven days a week sometimes
and they wouldn't take welfare or social
assistance they were too proud so I was
I hit a low point in New York City one
time and almost homeless and I literally
was getting high all the time on
different things and I was on the street
I had my hand out I was begging for
money and this older lady came by one
day and she looked at missing them
crafts changing she looked at me she
walked by I thought she was gone so I
asked the next person I thought little
tap on my back the same old lady I said
yes ma'am we got change
she looked at my face she she said son
do your mama know y'all here doing this
I said no man just shook your head just
walked away didn't give me a dime I
turned around I sit on the steps and
never beg for money again you still see
her face yes oh yes I turned then look
likes of what I walked her she walked
two blocks and took a left and I watched
her change my wife reminding him my
parents told me and I got a college
education and I had a master's degree
and blablabla my mother and father with
a 2nd and 3rd grade and they never asked
anybody for anything I had to carry that
legacy on changed my life and that mean
when people come to me with excuses and
stuff I always say to them you know you
got a lot excuses oh wow
life is hard huh Wow hmm sometimes tell
me come with me for a second get my car
ride down this street he left us what do
you write
I said do you want that oh no that's the
point I'm making as I'm not suggesting
it's easier that you're not suffering
but do you want that I mean you ain't
gotta look for you know it's their
suffering going on right here that's I
go down a fifth and spring you'll see
children crawling in and out of
dumpsters for food so what do you think
people under 25 or 30 not understand
about success in Hollywood maybe they
think oh I'll never be that you know
everybody always thinks I'll never I
could never end up like that which
sometimes it's just a matter of bad you
know circumstances piled up and one to
lead someone there and they think oh I
have a safety net it would never happen
to me but the general 25 30 year old
that comes out here with a degree genes
that are the plan is called frustration
there are two things I would address it
with one is the God joke you know you
know the guy took tell him your plans or
Oh or is that John Lennon like this wow
that's a good joke okay make God laugh
tell him your plans and I mean one thing
I find with it with the younger
generation now it might have a story of
uh been a minister that's a friend of
mine told me he said he said Bill you
know one one day I stood up in church
and I said to my congregation he said
everybody that wants to go to heaven
stand-up dance and sing hallelujah a
whole church fifteen hundred people come
up and he shouted for five to ten
minutes he took calm him down whoa whoa
okay okay okay okay
said uh my second question everybody
wants to die stand up and sing
hallelujah he said I got my third
question is it Howard hell you gonna go
to heaven if you don't die see everybody
wants to go to hell
but don't no damn body wanna die and
dying well Holly was about how do you
resurrect yourself after you're smashed
a couple of thousand times do you buy a
violin take a little self-pity moments
of having fear everything is and how
great you are and how mean they are and
that could go on for thirty years forty
years or do you take the initiative to
do something that changes that it's like
one or two choices giving up or moving
ahead and a lot of folks just
and these are people have been in the
street 20 years they talk to them oh
well you know how hard it is these damn
agents and these studios and networks
and really hmm it heard of the Internet
yeah but that doesn't then whoever so
podcast know why I don't know how how
could I learn that's too hard but you
expected their results what you're doing
the same thing let's call this sanity so
all you can do is tell people for your
loving caring tell people but not
everybody listens they they just don't
listen they're afraid to jump into the
pond you know it's like today it's a
whole new world in terms of this
industry and say there's a pond and the
success range is over there and a lot of
folks just jump in they can't swim but
the best they can and get to the other
side while they're doing that some of us
put our arm in the water to cool it's
too deep it's a to warm a lot of waves
out there by the time the pond cools
down and you start moving to the other
side and your little boat
there are signs put up other people who
took the chance and those signs say
entry fees you know why because they
deserve it
we over their cowardly thinking they
didn't wait they jumped you know if they
were gonna drown or not they they didn't
know anything they just know that
whatever over there I'll get some that
so I don't have that I don't want to be
here anyway it takes that kind of desire
on my wall in my office have a picture
which is my favorite favorite picture
it's it's an ostrich or a swan who's
swallowing a frog and the Frog is
halfway down this one's throat there's
one problem the Frog has its hands are
brown smarts squeezing and it smells
like and the title says never give up
you can be down their throat but as long
as you got your hands around that throat
can't swallow
but if someone says well I'm gonna be 30
in March so you know I'm just gonna pack
it in I'm not gonna make it here what
about this new pressure that's 30 under
30 25 at the top you know people in tech
developing apps whatever this this new
bar that we've we've said that we have
to be a certain age or if you haven't
might as well pack it in well the system
is set up for the youth and they assume
that whatever older ones of us have
survived and then wizardmon
knows that we have is irrelevant I just
pad I'm gonna build an a heads and say
good luck when I was a young man there
was a there was a saying I never forgot
it and it was when I was a young man I
thought my father to be a fool now that
I have grown older oh how wise he has
become it's when you're young you think
you know every damn thing until the life
smashes you in the face with the truth
of its indifference toward you and all
those dumb people that are you think are
older and you don't listen to I want you
did a couple of scars you'll see how
stupid they really are it's gonna be
scarred first you know because I was
talking and they don't know nothing your
generations in the past but when you get
crushed
and by crushed I don't mean by not being
successful asked what the cost today of
being successful is it's coming out so
you have success which paid for it and
so with that success comes shame because
she wanted the success more than your
self-respect you notice all these people
coming out now and saying this is the
price I've paid and I've been
dismissible for all these years but
thank God I can say me too and it took
something off of me can you imagine
being successful knowing the price you
paid and choking on it for the rest of
your life
hey everybody I'm just fine I'm just I'm
great and I don't care about what I had
to do except when I sleep at night I
can't sleep at night yeah what about
wanting notoriety
notoriety these days people will do
anything for notoriety sometimes I see
an intern I cannot I mean are they
really doing this he just pointed out to
me yesterday a friend of his is an
artist has been accused of sexual
harassment of three women
did he point out to me one of these
women has a website and every one when
she has hundreds of pictures on our
website write the most obscenely
provocatively sexually explicit pictures
that you can imagine but a victim of
this dude was getting no due process by
the way because she said so he's guilty
a friend of mine worked at CBS for 15
years and a woman said that five years
ago he looked at her in a suggestive
manner that made her feel uncomfortable
they fired him on the spot they don't
want the publicity so these days people
do things i sexual acts I mean
this guy was on this murderer was on and
he put a selfie up talking about how he
killed people and how he did it he
didn't use a gun because he wanted to
use a knife that and see them die slowly
and then there are little kids now
taking drugs and doing other kinds of
things online young girl's sexual acts
bullying and saying how brave I am and
little girls going to school 12 years
old with guns in their hunt their
backpack and people getting shot I mean
I mean for notoriety I guess being
famous now has taken the place of any
kind of self-worth as long as you like
me I'm okay and girl like myself because
you like me but when you're alone
doesn't that bother you doesn't mean I
don't understand how just having
recognition or having people know who
you are having Megan eyeballs I guess
that gives you identity these days and
that's just beginning of the next two
generations three to five common
mistakes you see new actors making onset
common mistakes
number one no actress for the most part
and some actors which just threw egos
were out of shape believed that acting
is about talking or speaking their minds
they have no understanding of the art of
listening we are having a conversation
what a conversation is you speak I
listen closely to what you're saying
because I want to respond to your
question most actors have memorized
their line so no matter how you say it
or what's anything they just respond
with their line on camera it looks like
no wait a minute she was crying Oh Becky
you want to go to the prom no no she was
crying when you give it a flower oh yeah
take two hey Becky you want to go to the
prom cut you don't have a long talk in
the corner okay second biggest mistake I
think is that
some actors are not collaborators you
know it's like they're so unsecured it's
like they're seen and some they go in
with attitude like well this is my Sikhs
have more lines than you you know so you
know and there's two people on the scene
it'd still be want to sing feeling the
monologue it's just you but there are
people's eagles who are so large that
you're not even there so it's like
that's how good they can be and that's
annoying as hell the third thing is
nerves
I mean I've literally seen I had to stop
shooting a scene because in the middle
of the scene the actor was sweating so
badly that we at the cut are you okay
when I say sweat I'm talking about
because internally they are so worried
about the fact that they're not doing it
right that they just something
internally happens and they just are
terrified and so as a director you get a
call and give them you know make sure
they know that they're protected make
sure it's if they you you gotta give me
assurance because acting is response
it's it's it's it's surrendering it's
not holding on to safety that's easy for
me to say but try it sometimes try going
in and trying to do it and you don't
know how it's gonna turn out
and you asked how was i how did it go
what's great can I see it you know it's
like you don't know how it was because
you were involved in it and not knowing
what to do is we're not feeling safe
that you've done it well it's it's it's
a challenge
well they say having a big ego and a
small you go is pretty much the same
thing it's just sort of different ways
of dealing with it having a big ego I
think is a sign of a small self regard
having a small ego is similar I think I
forgot is a name but a Wayne Dyer I love
Wayne Dyer and he said you know the key
to having a great life is to get rid of
your ego
the audience said what are you talking
about he said do you know what the word
ego stands for e.g oh he goes to the
born he says 'i edging g-god zero out
says your ego edges God out and without
that force in your life he says you have
nothing but empty accomplishments and he
says try eating those empty
accomplishments when you're sitting home
alone because nobody likes you in your a
mansion said it's more comfortable on
being on the street
you said but when you ride by that
person sitting on the street he looks
familiar
I think he's brilliant and true I know a
very wealthy people who are miserable
get a man and when he didn't throw the
whole cars into a hole closed until the
hole the casein didn't fill the whole
relationship then for the hole there's
something else you have to have I'm not
saying I know everything but I do know
because I've had a lot of it that all
those things don't some hole if you
don't have self love even if somebody
else loves you if you don't have self
love tell my daughter every day I say
you know never forget men treat you the
way they see you teach yourself don't
treat yourself the way you think he
should perceive you treat to sell
yourself the way you want to be treated
I think it's a general for people
I love quotes so I can give you three my
favorite quotes sounds great
can't be
trying to please everybody except you
yeah not good right people-pleasing
disease is a disease yeah
what happens to you when you need
something where they where they go and
what it's come the woodwork people hmm
when you're doing real good they come
out of the woodwork oh yes you're doing
bad right yeah I started them a little
bit well good people come out of the
woodwork Oh cousin bill I know how do we
come their cousin
but you have some quotes I know you said
you loved quotes bill yeah I got fourth
month in Churchill true power is an
individual's ability to move from
failure to failure with no loss of
enthusiasm anonymous aspire to inspire
before you expire anonymous if a man
does not seek humility humility will
seek the man and my final one anonymous
and your lifetime you will never see a
smaller package then the person wrapped
up in themselves
and I found each one of those to be true
I'm sure you're asked about the scene
constantly but the interrogation scene
from menace to society I wasn't you just
I know this is a probably you've at been
asked this question so much but if you
could just take us back to that day just
doing that scene what was it like for
you I just finished doing a film I would
think I was in Canada and acting in the
film and I rushed back and at the same
day that I came in I had to be on the
set Hughes brothers and I guess not
their work I'm like oh they were I read
the script and I loved it
there's only one scene and it's like the
way they set it up got me immediately
into the mood because the room was dark
except there were like three spotlights
one on the young boy one of the middle
of the table the gun was and one on
myself and everything else was in shadow
and the police had brought this young
man into this place to intimidate him
into telling the truth and so he was
sitting there really nervous you know he
thought he was smarter than everybody in
the in the room and so when I questioned
him it was like I first brought the gun
in put on the table and turned it toward
him but said to him you're not
necessarily getting out of here alive
there's nothing you can do about it what
are you gonna do we can all say that she
reached for the gun and we defended
ourselves and shot
we DeSales words we just won like that
that was that that was it that said it
when he saw that it was like oh boy okay
and we started asking them questions
I've got some questions about was he
there and he said no and he said you
left the beer here and you bought the
beer at this time you drank the beer at
this time then he was his I saw his
hands start shaking and then I asked him
the same question again and he man the
second time said a different time and
that's when I knew that I had them and
you know that little gang thought they
were so smart and we were so stupid
it was a number it was a it was a
feeling of joy when I said to him you
know something nigga fucked up right
no no no no nothing
you know he done fucked up right yeah
here's what's crazy I was in Brussels
Belgium I ran on five or six months ago
acting unit for Nicholas Cage call Mandy
right I'm sitting in a restaurant eating
food by myself
this young building kid comes up to me
and says you choose me sir but you know
you don't fucked up right
I laughed so hard but no matter what
country I go to I mean I've made a lot
of films as an actor and director and
the line that said to me the most around
the world no matter what city I cook
over and you know something there are
young kids that's what's amazing to me
they've all seen that picture I don't
know how they see it but they see it Leo
I'll repeat that line and older people
too so yes it's it's it's interesting
how has that impacted your life
I'm sure it's got to feel good that
people know your work yes at the same
time maybe you're surprised that they're
young kids that are seeing this film and
from all walks of life what does that
MIT do to someone what it means you did
a good job because you impacted them in
that way you also wish there is more
than shit they remember you for than
just that line but you know you're
appreciative of the fact that they've
seen your work and they appreciate what
you've done and that's always good you
know because I'm very self-critical in
my work and so when someone affirms that
what I've done it impacted them that's a
very rewarding it's very rewarding
they don't have to be kind they don't
have to come up to you they don't have
to they do at a certain age you think
you could think of it forgotten about
you haven't that's he worrying also
especially when young people do it in
four different countries has your
self-criticism lessened over the years
as you've seen life as you seen that
even the most perfect fall or what seems
to be not so perfect that were actually
saviors I mean I'm just like coming up a
stuff but you know how usually people
become less critical as they realize
that we're all human you talked about in
the beginning we won't go exactly what
you said so I don't have to repeat it
but no one's perfect and we're all human
we're all pretty much the same
when I was a young man I'm writing my
autobiography now and do a lot of
thinking the frame of this book one of
the things I learned I when I was young
I thought that wisdom was when you knew
everything but there's so much that you
now figured out what it's really about
then I started studying quantum physics
and other things and astrology and
in astronomy and other thing is that for
example not only had they not discovered
that how many planets there are don't
even nominee galaxies there are that
dark space that they're going into now
and the thing that I realize now that
I'm 74 be 75 this month is to never ever
stop asking why that's true wisdom to
understand how limited our pea brain is
you know Albert Einstein spoke on it you
know people think I'm wise no I'm not
why they say just like I'm always
wondering I'm always exploring I'm
always thinking I'm always trying to get
more information because it gives you a
recognition of who you really are
compared to the size of this you you go
outside at night to the beach you lie
down look at
sky there's no into it and you think of
yourself within that context it's not
that we don't have relevance it but
comparatively speaking
we are just no that's too big kind of
campus we're in there someplace
but our egos tell us through everything
there's nothing beyond and all that
garbage until something catastrophic
happens it make us question I don't wait
for the catastrophic I question every
day someone tells me this is affect okay
let me get back to you on that I love
Google
I don't like Wikipedia at all it's not
like a PD there is you know there's
young people doing research papers on
Wikipedia but when I google things and
go back to multiple research points and
find out how many different opinions
there are about the same thing and then
I have to think about it that that
expands my brain like that makes me
wrong I never thought of it that way
that's it that's exciting to me but
sitting back like this old wise person
who I figured it all out
that's all crap I don't hear from
anybody not that you have to not have
information that could help me in terms
of talking to you because you're humble
enough to recognize my humanity as I'm
humble enough to recognize yours that's
a different situation because you may
know some things I don't know and I want
to hear those things so I can start
thinking but if you're looking down at
me from this place of authority
or you know when my sister and I were
children there are two people we were
told to never question your minister and
your doctor well today those are the
people I question most cuz you're gonna
tell me what to believe you're giving me
your opinion of my life I'm getting
other opinions you know put them all
together and I'll make the decision not
you make the decision for me because I'm
responsible for my life
not you I appreciate your input I'm
gonna ask five other people like you to
give me your input to don't have ah okay
make a decision how do others in the
industry relate to your work ethic
they don't think I'm crazy I mean I
don't get it done I can't sleep now
no matter how tired I know if I don't
get it done my work that day I can't
sleep so I'm worried about it the next
day and okay how many hundred so I have
to get it you know just because it's in
and so I meditate and the meditation
helps me but they're respected because I
don't stop because I'm super super super
prepared enough to guess so I said a
week before we shoot they have every
shot every single setup and shot of the
movie on a piece of paper all they gotta
do is follow the map that I've created
I'm not saying they don't have the
freedom within that context to say hey
but what about this what about that
right but you have a map so they respect
that
familywize they she's wise never been
married
it's I've been very selfish and the
women in my life have hated that because
of my work ethic I try not to be my work
home but next day I'm gonna go prepared
I want to I want to be able to sew ok
let's have a few moments of camaraderie
and whatever ok great
I go work on the script and that's the
most that's not the most comforting of
things in a relationship because we owe
each other the attention that each other
needs and I've always struggled with
that I always have in relationships
I might and the other thing it sounds
crazy but being a black man in this
business I felt they always had to be
better not as good but better because as
good it's not good enough it's always
paranoid I could be super duper duper
super prepared I have to you know so I'm
speaking for more than myself as an
individual I'm speaking for culture
because we're judged like that you know
oh I didn't know it was gonna be that
good cause he's black he's a big guy you
know never want to be a B never want to
be an a a plus plus
it takes I almost think much when I work
it's always in my mind I can't explain
it assistant and this stuff I shot the
day before I know no I could have done
it better if I had few more hours I just
wanted to be better I want to be my
legacy that it's excellent it's
something that I gave a thousand percent
but I'm it's crazy too because you know
it's I could always be better you know
it's it's oh it could be different but
it's kind of like a little neurotic type
deal but it's Who I am as a creative
person some people know the level of
intimacy they're comfortable with and
I'm not talking about physical intimacy
I'm just talking about being amongst
people and some people are better just
focusing on a career I think they just
know that about themselves and
unfortunately he's gotten a bad rap but
if some people know that you know what a
career is the most important thing to me
and if I if I get someone into my world
I may end up hurting them because I'm
not going to be available for them how
can they be ok with that that's a good
question
it's a good question you have one or two
choices
I'm going to satisfy your needs and
ignore the truth of my own I'm gonna
satisfy my needs and they grow the truth
the relationships needs I tried this
once like like the person so much I
tried not taking a job and staying in
the house and watching the flowers grow
and doing all the things she liked and I
she was happy but there's the truth that
I realized something after a few months
of feeling resentment
and that eventually manifesting itself
so was it I was I was fulfilling the
desires
it wasn't happy because I was lacking
something I've always been a worker I
always wanted to work Oh work stimulates
me it gives me fulfilment it's not that
I need romantic fulfill make everybody
else I need love and caring like
everybody else but loving caring without
me feeling engaged in something I'm so
passionate about which is my work if I
gave that up I it's not good for a
relationship with me and it's in that
that's what that's what's so difficult
you know it's I think I spoil spoil my
goddaughter because it's like you know
since three we spent so much time
together and I helped raise her and
spoiled her and everything you know
because I don't think it was there
enough I just kept things things things
we've worked it out of course but it's
like she's travelled around the world in
many places and everything and that's
all good but she was saying look think
we just sit down and just meditate we
just sit down and just talk yes I do
that
I got everybody saying we were safe 74
gonna be 75 February 26 I have to still
be working so Wallace am I gonna do
retire just you know just sit in the
porch in the beach watch the flowers
grow and and enjoy the air and so that's
the rest of my life huh
enjoying the flowers suppose I could
discover how the flowers are made
suppose I could discover where the sky
came from we're suppose I could discover
where air comes from and the source of
reality and film it
I mean I mean one of the my heroes of
discovery he's older than me or some
working freemen with his new network and
and this whole probably about God you
know who and where is God what is God
where I mean these amazing thinkers cuz
he plays those questions himself and he
just his brilliance of going into those
topics and understanding God what does
that mean to cultures around the world
that's fascinating to me but he still
has an open mind he still wants to learn
and know that's inspiring I watched last
night Terry Bradshaw and the boxer I
forgot his name but so it's probably
better late than never
and these four older men they're in
their 70s and some in their eighties and
well this one young guy the son I think
Terry brought show calls with them
around the world and they visit places
they always want them visit before they
die but they do it together it's funny
it's inspiring it's powerful because
they don't stop they just know before I
I got a certain amount of time left I'm
gonna do everything everyone to do and
that there's something about that's
wonderful
it's beautiful because they don't say
I'm retiring and I'm gonna lay up in bed
and just watch the birds go by
they're flying the birds so it feels a
fly okay I love it that's life
a lot of my friends work at jobs they
hate for 35 years they work every day
but that to be admired health insurance
car payments house note send the kids to
college all the dreams they had they
gave him up when they were 20 was they
had children they retire and there may
be dead in five to nine years it's not
what I wanted
it's not what I want I hope I don't
probably dying a set you know something
I don't know I'm just saying oh my god
knows that but I mean I just want to do
something I wanted to do and these days
huh how was he in Spielberg and George
Lucas and and Clint Eastwood they no
stop some could have gotten mad and said
well then I'm out of here because you
don't appreciate me and you thought that
I was somebody else and I'm insulted but
you obviously probably didn't do that
right and and as they were following you
around again some people could have
gotten mad said these people were
breathing down my neck and they won't
leave me alone
but you you kept going with it I was one
of the first black directors in TV in
Hollywood before me it was Michael
Schultz like Stan Lathan and recapping a
junior
what to have that opportunity I went
through a lot I give an example of
things and I this is my book I was the
first black to return doubt was ever and
I was so happy I suppose it was a top
hit show on TV I've done a good job with
nice landing and other shows that Falcon
Crest and other shows they said okay
give you a shot come up to the gate
runner brother studios roll down the
window look at the security guard before
I could say a word that security guard
says them who are you delivering for I
said no no no I'm not delivering for
anybody I'm the first like director on
that was and I'm here early because I
want to be it's like this one close it
aside I'm always early so I pull over to
the side and it's like so be at nine
o'clock it's 8:30 that was eight 4850
compliment when I say kiss in the phone
he calls update office and let the Remi
back in the phone looked over at me back
on the phone puts the phone and say I'm
here a goes like this yes
that's my first day what year was this
late 70s early 80s in Los Angeles oh
yeah I buy the team says one day I was
doing um thought wouldn't crest go to my
motor home I'm not in my hand walk by
train back trading honest it
okay guys man up you got something to
say to me what's it to my face what are
you talking about sir
I heard what somebody said somebody call
me tell me stand up come on you're the
director the phone would never say that
we talking about you some mistake I
think that you misheard us get my tray
dead around walking to a motor home I'm
gonna set a felt press one day we're up
in Napa Valley and I'm filming and first
ad we're filming in a restaurant it's a
practical location so we're there you
know just to shoot and he's supposed to
be quiet in the kitchen but they're
gonna be told we're shooting him so the
first ad very arrogant guy we start
shooting had to cut us third time
because there's noise in the kitchen I
say cut say hey man there's noise and
the kids will to calm down he said he
says to me and I'm quoting in front of
the cast in the crew if you want him to
be quiet go back there and tell him your
own damn self by that time I really had
it sorry threw down my headset nose
pushing toward a guy Jane Wyman grabbed
me by my arm she looked me in my face
she said took a deep breath my
director's chair pon my headset back on
time for lunch came back she had fired
him she apologized for him see what I'm
saying so knowing that people wanted you
to fail but still holding that
confidence I mean we've all had times
when we've been tested and we can tell
someone's egging us on how have you
learned to keep your cool and now you
say you meditate there are people who
want you to fail but there are great
people like Jane Wyman I want you to
succeed and David Jacobs gave me several
more chances at Knott's landing and
Larry Hagman at Dallas my first did that
show first back-to-back twenty-hour was
who said to me nice to meet you young
man we're gonna get along real fine as
long as you have me out every day by
3:30 I guarantee you every day you'll be
up with 3:30 can you come back and do
more and more shows I could tell you
stories of people who there's some great
people in this industry I mean when I
say great I mean they don't have to give
you a shot because they're good human
beings and they see beyond your color to
your man it
and your ability that they do something
then that they don't do it loud they do
it because they're good people
and if you deserve it they give it to
you they give you the shot because they
gave you that chance you do more than
you better than you could ever do
because yo that to them and yourself
there's some damn good people in this
industry when I came along I met a few
of them that changed my life but that's
when I you know to be very honest with
you and a place in my biography I grew
up as a racist I hated all the way
people because of slavery and
segregation so my father and mother go
through I just hated wait wait just and
then go for the angry young black man
and that was tall it's awkward I didn't
talk much and I wrote journals and stuff
and he's to the old people I'll never
forget who changed my life mrs. Jean
Walker I'm English teacher very stoic
and like this walking in the class she
told me nine times that's write in my
journal when she was teaching I just
ignored her this they said white woman
one day she says Duke stay here after
class just give me that book I said what
the general give it to me I said like
give me anything she said if you don't
give me the journal I'll fail in the
class you can't pass to the general at
her
pissed-off hated her come back to class
at next several weeks before spring
break and looked at her like if I could
punch in your damn face man
Spring Break hints come back to class
and the first day I'm going into class
she's a Duke come here
she gives me back my journal in this
book I said what is this
she says the national poetry contest
book so what do you like we give this to
me for she says look on page 49 she put
two my poetry poems in there that one I
looked at her did somebody I hated she
had taken she read my book my journal
took the best poems out and submitted
them to a national poetry contest I won
I was speechless
and she knew I was speechless she says
there's nothing to say you're good at
what you do that changed my mind I
wasn't quite sure how to think about
race then because that never happened to
me and then I went to the Community
College and you know James Hall was the
Dean he was in the Navy and stuff and I
got a scholarship to Boston University
after Dutchess and I went there but you
know it was difficult I got a
scholarship for in classes but I had to
work for room and board and food and
everything I was working seven days a
week exhausted and my grades weren't
that great and Severus said oh they're
just going to the arts college
I decided I was gonna come home to the
Kip see I was going to stay there for
you you're quits bu and get a job make
money so I can save it for that at IBM I
went doing a summer of to visit my
friends at BU and I'm leaving dr. hall
see he says hey Duke come here I gotta
go doc says Duke come here come here
oh this guy's a boring ass white I can't
stand this I go into his office just to
be courteous he says have a seat
I said okay how you doing dude okay he's
going to Boston University right yeah
well I'm not I'm going but I'm quitting
I'm staying the kimchi for a year and
gonna go back next year racism no you're
not what are you talking about goes into
his vest pocket and he has an envelope
to me I said what is this he something
open it in the envelope we'll check his
own money that paid for three years
of my room and board at West University
I looked in this man's white man's face
I'm suppose that he doesn't say a word
look at each other
I just thank you he did not say a word
put out his hand and he said
don't disappoint me something happens to
your racism after that it's supposed to
be your evil enemy that's responsible
for that negative in your life and
everything the devil the system the
creature just gave me a check to cover
all of my expenses for three years how
do you hate that life changing
so I evolved you know in my humanity to
understand you cannot put a blanket on
any of everything it's all about human
being the person the individual who they
really are behind what their skin color
is behind what their words are their
possession it makes a little difference
to know the human if they respect you
you respect them simple arab chinese
japanese jewish white black green
hispanic those topical services that's a
limited perception you have the courage
to engage people at their level of
humanity you're living at it's easier to
dismiss you because I see you and I make
assumptions I learned a long time ago
and a s/s
you Emme means it makes an ass out of
you and ass out of me to us so and I was
taught by those two incidents it was
incredible
it wasn't for those two people I
wouldn't probably be here today and
never asked for anything
all they say is to be your best that's a
reward
it's a truth
true story and very people knew this
ever happened and I'm sitting up my
monitor one day and he says do you know
no standing behind so we talked about
quitting parks I said get out of here
working itself playing just know Gordon
Parks is standing in my pond he's one of
my heroes
so I turn around and he says don't get
up don't get up he walks to me
he puts my hand on my his hand on my
shoulder and he says I never stopped
just looked at him and walked away I was
like you know given signs from the
universe you know and he was one of the
things that propelled me into continuing
because whenever you get depressed or
something you want to stop and you don't
stop because of those people came along
and said don't you ever think of
stopping cuz I'm not gonna lie to you
there are times I wanted to give up
because it's like hard but then you
think of the people who loved you enough
to encourage you when you don't stop and
associate a family's legacy
could you justify stopping a hill yeah
is it unfair yes if you don't fit into
certain boxes is that prejudice yes are
there people who don't like it because
of the color your skin yes people don't
make it because she was smart isn't him
yes so I mean if the boogeyman is good
his foot on your neck you'd have one of
two choices he's 10 times bigger than
you see if we say he's 10 times bigger
than me he's 15 foot oh and my neck is
cracking I'm ice well surrender and go
that's one choice or if his what is near
your mouth you can bite this time I
choose toe biting because you know what
the boogie has totus it really does know
a little mediate chuggy that's good
snack has meditation helped you notice
gratitude because I think some people
see signs that do tell them to keep
going and and it sounds like you've
you've taken certain things and really
taken that to heart and know that this
wasn't just a coincidence or this this
was I I was meant to hear this I was
meant to have this hand on my shoulder I
was meant to have someone take away my
journal and what seems like a bad
and then she reads it it's personal but
then something great comes of it
meditation saved my life I was taught
meditation she and some little
meditation TM by a good friend of mine I
was in a Broadway play and doing very
well but I gotten into drugs because
there are times in which the struggle is
so difficult I was working and
challenges and that I just over long and
it ended up at a point where in a
Broadway play and I'd be late to work i
they told me don't be late anymore and
came read again and they said you're not
substitute but your understudy is going
in I got pissed off and dad and my
friend who saw this I'm said bill you're
sinking fast
man you have to do something but I said
like what he says I made like the drugs
in hunka Hall but try meditation see one
of those who people what they they like
here so it got worse and then she said
try it okay I mean I'll try ah here so I
tried it a couple of times it was
interesting but still taking drugs and
alcohol and then have to run on once she
said I'll tell you what I'll make a deal
she said if you meditate for six weeks
without taking any drugs or alcohol of
any kind and if you still want drugs and
alcohol
after six weeks I'll buy your ailments
of anything you want I'm thinking oh boy
an ounce of anything I want are you
kidding me I'll take this Deadwood
I just know what's gonna work wasn't
gonna work first two weeks I felt
something it was like I don't know
little more ease less stress second and
third week more focus fourth in the
fifth week the piece that I was getting
out of the drugs and alcohol I was
getting through meditation and more I
was getting a deeper sense of something
I can't even explain I haven't touched
drugs alcohol since that day and that
was in 1974 became a TM teacher it's
changed my life too I can't even tell
you it's it's hard to explain you know I
could tell you more stories about what
I've been through but that was God
working again to join me Chancellor
meditation I changed my life to for my
own salvation I could lay - who asked me
to turn around and Miss Walker and dr.
Hall it's and and I recognize these
things that he was gonna think I'm crazy
because I say oh god is doing this oh
whoa what should God look like I don't
know I know he's there I trust because
there are things that have happened that
I know I'll give you another example
it's in my book
in 1984 I was working really hard and
when your agent says you're so tired you
got to take a vacation the agent makes
10% what you make when you're agent tell
you to take a vacation you know that
you're exhausted so I took a vacation
with the why he because he had just get
married and don't hit the hotel no by
myself I just wanted to totally chill I
was there for a week that's well there's
eight of two weeks I said I want to come
back to this place never been it's
beautiful so I got in the plane called
island hoppers it goes from one island
to another into a ground toy and they
get Michael another Island
way to Maui from the Big Island and it
was a twin-engine claim I was said that
the planes are going so don't stop them
say to hell and it stops it was a oh so
laughing you know let's go says sit down
sit down sit down sit down sit down and
buckle your seats now usually in the
movies when the planes in trouble the
pilot says ladies and gentlemen he can't
be still over in control little bit the
pilot the powers doing help us Jesus
help us Mary help us lord help us Jesus
help us Mary help us Lord
the pilot looking out the window say no
we sure are close to the dam we crash in
the water no what is him soft right when
you hit the water from that height bam
bam it tore the boats out of my seat and
threw me forward the scar is from that
happening and when that happened this
it's hard to explain but it's an
out-of-body experience something there
look down and those sounds crazy
look down at me and my seat all the
people bleeding the pilot and everything
okay so this thing I can't explain what
it was it's peaceful just observing me
how it wakes up its face hit the
dashboard of the plane everybody else
get up Susie did it this thing in my
body merged back together and they said
Oh coz I don't swim I said I said it out
loud you always wanted to know how
you're gonna die now you know I just sat
there waiting for the water's coming up
boom boom boom bloods coming up boom
boom boom boom
Paula's people out takes them to the
wing just hey you come on let's go let's
go let's go I said I can't swim he says
unbuckle your seat okay I'm booked on my
seat take a life throw that out
I've thrown up put it around your head
it gives the instructions pull of course
when I got this shorter like five chords
looked down into a thousand I kept
pulling and pulling and pulling and
pulling and pulling and pulling nothing
after you left there places come to the
wing I said I don't see this come to the
wing I got the wing I'm standing there
and they all paddled away cuz they all
family everything gotta go five or six
hundred feet away he says jump jump
undertow undertow I said I can't
somebody says jump I said to myself what
the hell have to lose I'm gonna die
anyway so I jumped I forgot to tie the
life don't around my waist because he
had owned he had pulled a cord as I yeah
I passed them blew up I've got tired of
my waist and with that once twice third
time I came up life I'm not exaggerating
life doughnuts here I put it around my
head
like a little dog I do like this then I
reach them
I recently turned around there's a big
mouth of water swallows the plane and
takes it wonder if I stayed on the wing
I would have died
I'm telling us all the truth I'm telling
you in the water ten minute passes
people are moaning and groaning lady
says look boats planes boats planes my
thought is you know before you die
because there's sharks in the world and
everything you have these delusional
thoughts and you think you see things
that's what she's doing right that's it
just boats planes boats planes take this
to Vegas you tell me the chances of this
happening twice a year
the Hawaii Fire Department since its
emergency rescue teams out to do
practices in all different parts of the
ocean this day they were one half
nautical miles away from us they saw our
plane go in there were there in minutes
they took everybody out the water raft
us in blankets asked if he okay I
started driving us back to shore I said
next a pilot
six foot two or three Ichabod Crane blue
eyes I could see his face dark here with
white streaks through it sitting he's
shivering on Chevron and I say to him
sir I don't wanna disturb you
I said that I was in shock you talked me
through getting out of the plane you
talked me into jumping off I talked me
to Pavan toward you saved my life and I
want to I want to thank you I cannot
know what to say he looks at me and he
says I appreciate you saying that he
said I'm not on the Catholic I believe
in Jesus Christ he says I don't know
what you believe in
he said but don't thank me thank that
turns away from me
the speck of my face grabs my shoulder
and starts crying like a baby
get back - sure people are in shock
because planes that crash in that Widodo
have survivors
I have no way of explaining it to say
that that's one of the day that I
realized there are things happening in
this universe that are far beyond my
intellect far beyond my intellect and I
had my two masters degrees and I was so
smart I can't even tell you how much I
learned from that experience I pictures
on a wall of my conduct there of that
day the newspaper I saved it and just
framed it I never want to forget it it's
just so it shaped my life between those
experiences and meditation to shape my
life and maybe understand that you know
and you're writing a biography
autobiography so I'm gonna steal a
c-span question I've watched the post
and they interviewed Katherine Graham
years ago and she wrote a tell-all book
about the post and her family and the
troubles with her husband and his
depression things like that and the
interviewer said why do you want people
to know this she said good question I
started and I was only gonna tell one
thing and I just I kept going I couldn't
stop I'm writing this book for all the
losers in the world for all the people
that have been told you cannot do it
you're a loser you're too stupid you're
too ugly or to a dummy or to black or to
whatever you're never gonna make it
I've been called all those things and
worse
I'm writing this book because I want
children who are going through similar
things and never give up on themselves I
can get through it so can you
never never whether you're five or a
hundred never give up it's never too
late you determine your reality are
there forces that helps shape that the
context around you of course there are I
mean but what is your responsibility
because the boogeyman's bigger than you
you don't you don't fight back you don't
do nothing you don't buy this tow you
don't do nothing you just talk about the
size of the book in the hand how long
he's been on your neck the color of the
boogeyman the boogeyman system or the
boogie Mans how can you say the order of
his breath you can describe every aspect
of the boogeyman for the rest of your
damn life or you can buy this dope now
ya ain't gonna kill with you buy this
though but tolls are sensitive there's
gonna be some movement well you needs a
little bit a little bit
gen-i gonna bite well that's your
definition of your possibilities in life
I can't bite because the boogeyman so
big and I'm so weak goodbye shit sorry
not me
never
you gotta have my guess a couple of
bullets they were to hit something
that's vital because they can remove
them I'm coming back never give up never
and as I feel needless to say to the
people who try to stop you and put you
down it's only one phrase that they
deserve and that is this - dumb as you
look
my name is damn dumb as you look
we can keep talking I want you to know
something - dumb as you look
you know it's interesting once they see
that who Ortiz they know that you're not
playing checkers in a chess game you're
playing chess my mom was a both playing
chest let's play so I got some damn
moves - let's just play don't tell me
y'all gonna check up late I am
that's why I feel
I would imagine though that you get
emails every day from people who are
asking for career advice can you tell
from some of the emails those who really
want help and those you may not be able
to help yes there are people who somehow
I think someone's gonna be given to them
and there are other people who reach out
to you for guidance of how they can get
it themselves the people who ask for
guidance of how they can get it for
themselves I'm interested in them
because they're not asking me to do it
for them they're saying you've had
experience and I'm willing to listen to
you so I don't make crazy mistakes and
so those people like you're late to
because somebody did that for me but
people who come out and they just want
as you so eloquently spoke before it but
not a variety they're not serious about
this industry not serious about being a
great actor or a great writer and great
producer a great director they just want
to be seen and that people know who they
are I don't take them seriously and
our foundation it's called the media
foundation you teach kids media literacy
which other what are the jobs of the
future gonna be and financial literacy
if you make money how do you not just
spend it and use it and so kids young
kids that are serious if we can get an
opportunity to help them we do I think
there's a validity in coming out here
with dreams and one used to be I guess
recognized and writing but that's not a
serious crafter in history that's just
some of the securities you have that you
want overcome so when you receive an
email how can you tell the ones that
really are looking to find ways how they
can then do it themselves
and those who just want sort of a hand
up they say it they're very clear I mean
you know there's some people who are so
unaware of how this place works they'll
say like oh I want to agent and I know
you have an agent can introduce you to
your agent I'm saying you have any
pictures I don't have any pictures okay
give it real no I don't have a real have
you ever acted in a home or a play
nobody have an acting teacher and and
people think I'm handsome they really
think I'm beautiful and they have I
think they think I'm talented
what do you say to that I mean I I
thought okay I God knows I wish you luck
but you're coming out here with nothing
you want me to just drive you my agent
it doesn't work that way then there are
kids they have pictures resume decks if
they have a project they adducts for
their project pictures actors attached
they didn't the research for the
demographic of what they're trying to
sell to the return on your investment
how much money it now when I see that
whoa come here
let's talk because you're serious III
can still I can teach you but you don't
need that much teaching all you need is
opportunity it's just a different
experience
I'm just looking for I wanna meet your
agents I don't be mean but I just can't
I can't do that agent says to me why did
you bring that person here they wanted
to meet you
that's not good
is there any mistake that you made early
on in your career that you said never
again and it's not so much working with
someone or whatever it's more something
either you did or something you didn't
pick up on about a situation that cost
you and you said I will never I was
offered a role I'm not gonna tell you
the roles it was a TV show I tell us
payment playing this role that I did not
like I think it was an embarrassing role
with him but I have been trying to get a
job in TV for like three years and
couldn't get anything rejection
rejection reject so for this role
audition and I got the wrong and friends
of mine saw the script they said don't
do it totally broke meant let's do I
able to give me some something it was a
hit TV show - I did I did it when I saw
the footages oh my god nobody sees and
maybe five to seven years later when I
had some real money
I called the network and tried to buy I
tried to buy the footage back that I was
in and to buy the episode and I said I'd
pay whatever they it wouldn't sell it to
me I saw him there was but
needed the money needed the job
haven't done it since then
but I understand and before that is to
put down the step-in Fetchit I just put
down through that came before me that
did you know they smiled laughed and
dancing didn't act like you know happy
black people then maids and butlers and
stuff when they said their shaming the
race and then oh no they took their jobs
that were offered to them at that time
to do the best that they could what they
had and my respect for them changed
totally because I was faced with the
same thing I could understand why they
did what they did but I was fortunate
enough not to have to do it again I have
had to do it sense but and I still get
these opportunities but to turn down
something mechanical a lot of money a
lot of people would see but it's totally
against everything you stand for as an
actor and artist and everything I mean
certain people put down certain people
because of what they did in the show or
whatever or not I don't I don't do that
anymore I just say you don't know their
circumstance you got a sick baby at home
you got a sick baby you don't got take
care of your bills I don't know his
business I am not fond of reality TV
though I got I'm not gonna lie I was in
out of the country and I was asked
questions about my culture based on
metal alloy the TV and I was saying know
it that's not the way every black person
in the world not every black person's
woman dragged across the hey what's the
Fleur by their hair and and every black
man wears his pants below his butt
we thought all blacks said no because we
were looking at your pants we wonder why
you didn't have your pierced missus in
Belgium when you you stopped them one
guy at the restaurant not nothing
against Belgium but I just wondering if
it was the same trip like what this one
I was in China years ago that was in
China that was in China and I was in
Japan and Tokyo and they just it said
there's something wrong with me because
I didn't look like the regular black
people
he said you speak good - did they know
your work some of them did but at that
time not a lot of them they just oh
you're here filming oh good good I have
some questions for you you know I was in
shotgun away but not in the way you know
because I know the stuff that gets to
them that's how they see us as a culture
and I just was amazed by how many people
followed us that way but media is very
powerful and that's whatever they see
that's who you are
going back real quickly 1984 you said it
was a book that you would be one of the
five books that she would take with you
if you couldn't read any other books I
was just curious why 1984 I want to get
in trouble for this but in 1984
something worth living today your drove
all my favourite books at the time but
I've been reading looking at the film
and reading the book since this last
election and it has a section about the
thought police you guys have read that
Medina for
I know parts of it I haven't read it by
George where well yes but I've heard the
whole concept about what the thought
police
but the thought police and 1984 I mean
you're not allowed to do anything
without the permission of the thought
police and they determine the reality
they create this war that's not looking
at what's happening at all they have
these soldiers marching and all this
stuff and blablablabla that you nothing
allowed to have a relationship without
definition can't just fall in love yet
the other commission let's go through
them so Richard Burton is the head of
the thought police and John great actor
John forgot his name he is a citizen and
he and this young girl fall in love they
keep meeting secretly at his place in
her place and running away and money one
day that I thought God but I thought
police and helicopters coming the
soldiers come in and kept available and
take them to the fuck Police
Headquarters and John the actor forgot
his name was going on
table I thought police headquarters and
there's a spotlight on the table he's
lying there naked with his hands tied
and his feet tied and symmetrical force
comes with it to the table what a switch
that if you try to switch on it just
electrocute you
and that's water coming down so it's a
guy near the button in Richard Burton is
sitting there in Javas I'm so sorry I
was wrong
I did I did the wrong thing I apologize
I never should have ever ever ever seen
her and then I imagine Brittany says
well you know she said that you started
it he said well I don't I don't know I
just he says okay and he says
I'll never do it again please forgive me
free just when I trust but verify
so he says to Jesus how many things am i
holding up John says four but you
Britain NASA the guy with the button
when I do wrong what do they what's
wrong
how many fingers I'm holding up for what
did I do wrong
how many fingers am i holding up I don't
know I don't know better how many
fingers am i holding up
three-three I'm holding up as many
fingers because I tell you yes I'm
holding up
you got nothing dude your eyes nothing
dude your intellect or your mind
I say it's three fingers how many are
they
three three alternative fact is in three
an alternate effect you won't believe
what we tell you to believe nothing to
do with your perspective at all okay not
me